solve for x and we have the absolute
value of 2x minus 5 is equal to 11 now
the big I guess insight you need to have
whenever you have an absolute value
equation like this is just to remember
if I have if I have the absolute value
of a is equal to 11 what do we know
about a that means that a is either 11
that means that a is equal to 11 or what
else could a B well it could be negative
11 a could be equal to negative 11
because there's two possible aids that
are exactly 11 away from zero it could
be positive 11 or it could be negative
11 that's the exact same logic you apply
to an equation like this if the absolute
value of 2x minus 5 is equal to 11 that
means that this stuff inside the
absolute value sign either equals 11 or
the stuff inside the absolute value sign
is equal to negative 11 because if this
is equal to 11 the absolute value of 11
is 11 if this thing over here is equal
to negative 11 when you take its
absolute value it'll still be equal to
11 so let's write that down so 2x minus
5 could be equal to 11 or or 2x minus 5
could be equal to negative 11 right
because in either case we took its
absolute value you would get 11 now
let's just solve each of these equations
over here we can add 5 to both sides we
can add 5 to both sides of this equation
we get 11 plus 5 is 16 2 X minus 5 plus
5 is just 2 X 2 X is equal to 16 divide
both sides by 2 we get X is equal to 8
now let's do this situation 2x minus 5
is equal to negative 11 let's add 5 to
both sides of this equation the
left-hand side we just get a 2x the 5s
cancel out 2x is equal to negative 5
plus 11 that's negative 6 negative 6 now
we can divide both sides by 2 divide
both sides by 2 and we get X is equal to
negative 3 so we've gotten to solution
depending on whether this thing in here
is either equal to 11 or negative 11 we
got X could be equal to 8 in which case
2x minus 5 would be 11 or we have X is
equal to negative 3 in which case 2x
minus 5 is equal to negative 11 let's
let's verify it so if X is equal to 8
let's let's show that it satisfies this
equation so we would get 2 times 8 minus
5 the absolute value of 2 times 8 minus
5 should be equal to 11 2 times 8 is 16
minus 5 is 11 so we have the absolute
value of 11 should be equal to 11 and we
know that's true
I'll let the absolute value of 11 is 11
so it all works out now let's try it
with X is equal to negative 3 we get the
absolute value of 2 times negative 3
minus 5 should be equal to 11
so what's 2 times negative 3 2 times
negative 3 is negative 6 minus 5 the
absolute value of that should be equal
to 11 well negative 6 minus 5 is
negative 11 so the absolute value of
negative 11 should be equal to 11 and it
is the absolute value of negative 11 is
11 so we get 11 is equal to 11
so they both work